his wrestling name his real name was
high chief Peter Maivia and he was a
high chief of Samoa and he actually
started his career here in in England oh
and then he was trained English style
and at that time in the sixties I
believe English style wrestling was
there was a lot of what's called shoot
wrestling like derived from shoe fight
which eventually became MMA so it was
very tough style of wrestling here in
England and and yeah so that's how he
was trained and we've got that picture
of him not is this him as a recipe that
is kind of like his stay here was that
him in Samoa that's him as a pro
wrestler but wearing his high chief gear
and is it true that in moaña
that your character was based on him
sure correct so a lot of the the details
of that character Maui was based off of
my grandfather with the long hair and
very big build and tattoos and in
Polynesian culture in San Juan culture
you to become a high chief you have
tattoos 360 degrees from your knees all
the way up to the bottom of your chest
everything and in its hardcore and they
do with attack working around what the
cash and prizes is yes lift it and then
you do you get sort of children wanting
you to kind of delight them as as Maui
all the time all the time like it's
constant it's always constant oh you
sing songs sing your song sing your song
and I do it and then and then they cheer
and then I go say okay we'll have a good
day have a great day
the last day I I can't
I don't know that looked like a man who
wants to I don't know
alright let's see
let's go right into the catfight and
this is what the kids lunch so it's
alright listen kid honestly I could go
on and on I could explain every natural
phenomenon the tide the grass the ground
oh that was Maui just messing around I
kill Daniel and I buried its guts
sprouted a tree now you got coconuts
what's the lesson what does it take away
don't mess with Maui when he's on a
breakaway and the tapestry here on my
skin is a map of the victories I win
look where I've been I make everything
happen
look at that meaning man would you think
it did happen
[Applause]
[Music]